a couple months ago I received a text
message from an unknown number now
usually I don't respond to unknown
numbers but this was different the text
read hey miss Edwards it's Shaddai I
merely respond back where are you how
are you are you still in school and then
I flashed back to a moment about two
years ago when I was working as director
of operations of a charter school in
newark new jersey today was one of my
students and we had formed a very
special bond but on this particular day
shaday had been kicked out of school for
cursing out the school principal now I
had a feeling there was more to the
story so I took it upon myself to leave
the school building and go find her and
find out what really happened so I walk
out the building and as soon as I step
outside I see shadae sitting on the
steps of a church next to the school and
she's crying so I walk over to shaday
and I sit down next to her ask her
what's going on I soon find out that
shaday wasn't particularly angry with
the school principal that day she just
really really missed her dad you see the
year before Shaw days father had passed
away but her family was too poor to
afford a tombstone so her father was
cremated against both his and his
family's wishes shaday was upset that
day because on that day she just wanted
a physical place to remember her father
and she had nothing so she was upset so
at this point I look at Shaw day and I
tell her Shaddai give me your phone I'm
going to call your mom we'll make sure
you get home safe and don't worry about
the principal I'll just make sure you
get back to your family right now and
then shaday looks up at me and she goes
he took my phone I said who took your
phone
I day and she said the man like okay but
what what man Sharda she said the man
was the gun right before you came you
put the gun in my face and he took my
phone at this point I just have to stop
I look around me it's broad daylight
it's lunchtime just like it is right now
I hear laughter in the distance an
argument down the street and here we are
sitting on the steps of a church and a
young girl morning her father had just
been robbed at gunpoint for her cell
phone and in that moment I realized
there's no education reform there's no
large-scale theory of change or impact
model there's no design thinking white
boards or post-it notes no case study
that would have ever prepared me for how
to react in that moment so instead shot
I leaned on my shoulder and cry and I
tried not to cry the next time I turned
and looked at Shaw day I felt like I saw
the world in her eyes the world she was
living in seemed so dark so unfair so
scary but the world that I saw living in
her was when dominated by her godlike
personal strength and it was then that I
realized a greater truth about life we
all may live in this world yet we choose
how we let the world live in us if we
fast-forward to today Sade's mother is a
drug addict and to this day I have no
idea where in the world Shaddai is
anyone looking at her records with D her
poor grades her poor behavior her lack
of attendance rate or even her dropout
rate at this point but they what the
records don't show is that I seen
something divine in that child
today I am NOT speaking to you as the
future of business leaders and
entrepreneurs and policymakers which I
know you all will become one day instead
I'm coming to you humbly under the most
basic common denominator that connects
me you Mark Zuckerberg Beyonce and even
Shaddai our humanity you see at the GSB
we talk about changing the world as if
the world is world is some vague distant
thing that we will magically reenter
after we graduate but the truth about
the world is this we are it the world is
now the world is here it is so easy to
get caught up in school work politics
and the very visible differences that
divide and separate everyone sitting in
this room today but if we want to take
if we want to change the world we have
to be willing to look beyond was visible
to the eye on other people now you may
call this seeing God or the divine in
someone you may call this acknowledging
someone's humanity whatever we call it
we have to choose to see something
greater in ourselves and other people
because in the absence of something
greater we must miss out on the bigger
picture about life that life is not
about us life is about the value we
create and the legacy will leave behind
and if we don't see anything greater in
ourselves or the people around us our
legacy will end as soon as our lives end
but if we take the time to see and
believe in something beyond ourselves
and align our work with a higher cause
or a higher purpose not only will it
lives be much richer but the work we do
will live forever so
how do we begin seeing more and other
people and in ourselves well the answer
is we're going to have to rediscover our
sense of wonder and all in the world
Albert Einstein once said he who can no
longer wonder and stand wrapped in all
is as good as dead his eyes are closed
as a child it's very natural for us to
wonder and stand and off and stand in
all of the world but as adults we tend
to assume that we know everything that
the world's about wonder is defined as a
heightened state of consciousness
brought upon by something so beautiful
something so rare so an unexpected
something that is a marvel it was a
wonder for me to see the strength in
shaa day as she warned the passing of
her father today it is a wonder that I'm
even able to talk in front of you are
and for some of us in the room it was a
marvel to even get out of bed this
morning Wonder has been shown to be one
of the most important emotional
foundations underlying optimum mental
health and not only is it linked to
improved health but the capacity for
experiencing Wonder and awe has been
linked to improve our abilities to build
stronger more cohesive teams and
communities so my challenge to you today
go home and write down one wonder you
saw on someone else today one wonder
that enriched your understanding of your
world I promise if you do this you
experience the world in a much deeper
and richer way than you ever have before
I have realized that I may never hear
back from Shaddai again I may never have
the answers to the questions that I
texted her but what I do know is that my
life is so much richer because I took
the time to see the world in her what
will people say when they look at you
thank you
you